I am here with Alexander lenderon
Alexander first of all congratulations
big victory against a very difficult
opponent Christopher was surging through
the rankings won his last two games but
you came out with this very intriguing
idea in the opening take us through uh
that yeah I mean I was trying to prepare
the best I can before the tournament
um you know in general I always try to
save my best ideas for a tournament like
this um
so yeah because I think yeah if you
don't have good prep it's very difficult
to play against all these very strong
opponents so at least I wanted some kind
of an advantage
um yeah I think it worked out pretty
well uh this 95 move in the Catalan it's
like it's not your uh
yeah not not so common I've never played
it before my my friend gave me some
ideas here who's your friend well if you
don't mind maybe I guess you do maybe if
I uh you know uh top three in the
tournament I can reveal or something
absolutely but yeah for now uh uh keep
it secret we'll leave a friend's secret
yes yeah but um yeah but I mean the most
common move instead of 95 of course is
castles and then usually Knight C6 and
there's like lots of theory I've played
games on the white side before yeah 95
is more ambitious line you know you're
sacking a pawn usually here and actually
go back
um it was uh interesting because
actually during game 995 castles and
Christopher was hovering around the B
Pawn and I thought maybe he maybe he'll
play B5 but no I didn't get such luck
because okay 95 ed5 uh Knight C4
I was just to interrupt you for a second
Alice Lee uh the last game pending ended
up in a draw let's continue yeah so the
bit pity that that didn't happen but
okay it's uh it's it's it's it's fine
yeah uh so it's not like you're
completely winning right I mean
obviously yeah very good position but
right so so yeah he played the main line
castles 94 B5 B3 and the main line is
cb3 of course
um maybe three
you know yeah there's like a lot of
theory after that uh probably black
should be sort of okay but he needs to
know a lot a lot yeah he played C3 I
vaguely tried to recall my prep here and
I think I recalled it correctly and I
guess I got a pretty good position but
maybe I misplayed it so you did actually
you were it felt like you were
completely winning at this point almost
um yeah I was told after the game that
apparently nights at 63 yeah basically
what I missed was that after Knight
takes D4 Knight takes D5 ed5 Knight F4
C6 yes I missed Queen C3 ah got it yeah
although apparent the queen D1 was also
good but I mean I did Step in Time
calculate but unfortunately that was
like a Miss for me in this game yeah
thankfully didn't end up causing it
still I mean it's not that easy and
you're not spoiling your advantage with
the move that you played not completely
I mean I I felt like this should be very
good for me but I just I was spending a
lot of time I just couldn't quite find
the best way did you feel like you let
him back in the game at any point oh
yeah for sure at some point I thought it
was like very much close to equal also I
also can we go back a few more sure yes
so on move 21
um Knight A4 yeah instead of Knight F4
uh I was kind of kicking myself for
playing Knight F4 I was wondering if
Knight E4 was the move also absolutely
yeah yeah and then uh because then C2
maybe I can take kind of six
uh oh but it's actually not good because
the night before oh wow good thing I
didn't do it I mean night before is also
such a crazy movie yeah I I didn't see
yeah I was kind of I somehow I just
missed C2 it was a bit strange but I
felt like I was missing a lot of stuff
here and no 94 Knight A4 actually was
the best move according to the engine so
okay so Knight C3 and Rook C5 I didn't
see at all but yeah I guess it
transposes to this position anyway which
I thought is quite a bit better for me
but I uh definitely no risk for me but I
didn't really see how exactly to play
and The Limited material I mean if he
exchanges one Pawn then
yeah I guess somewhere here I okay
Bishop is six rookie five yeah and here
my original intention was something like
uh Bishop F1 or Bishop yeah but then I
realized Queen B3 just doesn't uh Queen
C5 Queen B2 somehow
yeah uh and I think I also calculated
something with uh maybe bishop E4
instead of Bishop F1 or maybe Queen C3
instead of Bishop of one Queen C3 yes I
was looking at that but then still yeah
he's been taken yeah and I just realized
it's not that great because there's
always pressure on F2 so yeah I kind of
reluctant to play Rook B1 but apparently
it was a good move I still keep the
tension and still a little bit better so
yeah I mean I was I was kind of hoping
for the best I mean his King is a bit
weakened and what was the last mistake
that he made
uh what do you feel like the last you
know I'm not really sure because it was
uh or it was just a build up I thought
it was like heading for toward the draw
and there was like Mutual time scramble
but then like by the time we got to move
40 I thought I might already be winning
concretely so I I think you were indeed
uh yeah so I'm not exactly sure
especially this move G5 which yeah G5
looks very interesting but I guess I
calculated well here that I mean I
thought H5 also maybe should be very
promising in well G5 H5 yes but uh but I
think I calculated well here hghg yes
and then uh I think that it's important
instead of Bishop C4 if I go King G1 I
think it's Rook C8 and so that's that's
why it's important to start with Bishop
C4
um yeah so I was happy that at least
that in the end I played precisely but
yeah it was a great battle Alexander
congratulations your first victory at
the 2022 USS Championship thank you so
much